what oh we gotta yeah make sure to make
sure to hide the
the secrets are there any secrets are
there any see
just put the secrets in the cabinet uh
don't worry it's just facing me right
now
no one can see any secrets you're going
to cover it with a cloth
is it covered no it's not a cover do we
have something to cover
the secrets with there are some secrets
no yeah not yet we gotta we gotta give
some people some time to get in here
someone wanna someone want to ping him
on discord
stream today oh [ __ ] i went vertical
orientation is locked yo we're streaming
no no we'll go we'll go horizontal
we'll go we're going horizontal we go
i don't know if that's horizontal oh i
didn't plan this out
is this still vertical i don't know
nope we can't we're doing a vertical
stream today it's all vertical boys it's
all vertical
yeah yeah look at this the turn does
exceed the steering limit
we got open pilot wow
would you like to talk about it yeah i
mean we have carla which is a simulator
and then now the car here is being
driven by open pilot
so yeah thanks guys you can see
uh you can actually
increase the speed how how easy is this
going to be to set up on my computer at
home
oh it's two lines wow wow two lines
wow yeah yeah yeah set up to increase
the set speed
see we increase the speed to 30. it's
just like open pilot in your car
except just car law
yeah it's going to run a red light
yeah i don't know it's going to it's
going to oh guys we got to add red light
detection
oh it was green oh that was good that
was good that's close
wow that that model's that model is
working well
oh that's oh that's solid
oh that's solid
wow i didn't know open pilot could make
turns like that
yeah yeah yeah let's let's make this
let's drive it faster
oh no all right so who wants to want to
talk to the camera
sorry you're you're it's all it's all
it's all vertical
i know it's friday night that's what
you're doing
thank you thank you uh
i'm just waiting for it to finish the
time okay crank it up
we want to see a crash virtual cars are
cheap
but why is it not accelerating
[Music]
it's because it's in a curve it's in a
curve it doesn't accelerate in curves
the end-to-end longitudinal model is
telling it not to accelerate
we have good cover oh that's the secrets
under there
oh yeah good oh that's covered huh
that's good
that's good i think it's in a turn which
is why it's not accessible
so what's going on here we have open
pilot driving this virtual car
oh is it going to accelerate
it's virtually a car wait can we add
some traffic
yeah we can i mean yeah we can just put
uh just just
like does that work oh we haven't tried
oh we should try it yeah we can try it
the streamers love it when we try new
things right in front of them
in fact you guys can connect to our
server right now
[Music]
well maybe this car is maxed at 32
or is it not throttling enough what's
the throttle that's a lot of throttle
already yeah
i think it's i think this is the max
carla clips it at one
which one takes inputs from zero i think
i am clipping it out
0.6 i think yeah it's running to panda
safety
also guys we're switching the pie torch
who else is done with tensorflow
uh that's what i've been doing all day
what else this is this is pretty good
who else who wants who's got anything
else to say
[Music]
what are we missing oh oh something's
happening
oh wow it's still driving that was close
it almost crashed
all right how do we make a crash hello
from the amsterdam office
you're in the amsterdam office
rotterdam i can i'm i think i'm manually
increasing
it in europe right now
yeah i think this is the max star oh but
you're in manual mode now
yeah that's why i turn exceed steering
limit you know open pilot does that in
real life too
can you hand it back to openpop yeah i
can hand it back
yeah it's back cool
so that was the max throttle yeah i
think that's the max for this car well
what kind of weak ass tesla
is this must be out of batteries do we
set the battery though
yeah it's actually yeah it's the tesla
frame tesla wheels with the civic dvc
oh that's like yeah yeah i mean who
knows
all right that was today's today's
vertical stream
uh hopefully that's coming to an open
pilot near you it's just two docker
commands
yeah it's carla's docker right yes so we
just run carla's docker and then you run
sim is a new docker image we're
publishing every hour nice
open pilot sim we want to make it as
easy to use as baidu apollo
easier easier to use
that we haven't talked about yet what do
we have got the nissan harness
oh yeah yeah yeah apollo
all right what you got new products to
talk about yes so we got
the nissan harness which works on pro
pilot this is a big
this is the largest connector i've ever
seen are we charging more for this
no it also comes with a long usb cable
we have
all these wires and an extra long usb
cable for the same
price you guys that's the steel tomorrow
i might find out about this and raise
the price
we also have the obd2 harness which just
came out
um it's for volt people that looks like
a calm of power why i already have a
comet power why do i need to buy another
one
totally different because there's a usbc
port yo can i charge my phone with that
probably not i don't know
what happens if i plug my phone in
don't do it nothing
um yeah what now for all those volt
people who have been stuck on eons you
can now
upgrade to the comma two of this does it
have gm land
has gm land yeah no way how would you
fit gm land in there
ask robes uh
yeah uh this guy wants to know if he can
charge his vape
no i think it'll explode bro
yeah yeah does it conform to obesity
all these people will be millionaires
yeah that's right bravo that's right
[ __ ] crashed
would have been great if we got that
live live footage of the crash
minecraft can we reset it yeah wait how
do we put another car in there
how do we yeah well it's the same carlos
server right you can just
[Music]
is this like a one-liner that we can do
now no probably not
oh yeah we need we needed to follow a
car
that'd be cool that'd be cool yeah
don't kill us all in your hubris how am
i gonna kill you bro
don't worry a poor gps
don't worry guys no no no real cars were
harmed in the making of this video
oh
oh legit well that model is legit is
that new segment model
uh no it's not it's a secret good model
oh the secret good model
was it trained using infiniband and
melanox yo
no real talk guys we spent a lot of
uh money on infiniband network cards
and i don't know about them
[Laughter]
everyone's been gambling for all the
office furniture
alex alex doesn't like any of our
furniture so we got like new stuff oh
you guys want to see it
i'll show them the new little area look
wow this is this is pretty nice
yo this is a cool office it's improved
significantly since before
um this
is our yeah you can like sit here
and this is our large traffic light
um these are going in our not a data
center
oh we're hanging the traffic light we
hanging it up there yeah
nice yeah these are going in are not a
data center
does open pilot have parking assist
here's here's where everybody's using
open pilot right now
here's all the drives from today vivek
made this it's very
cool yeah look at them
this is yeah we got god mode yo uh this
is our driving
evaluation metrics page beta uh
yeah wow office has come a long way
look people have started driving only on
the weekends now
instead of the weekdays
we're at 25 million miles
how many parameters will be needed for
level four well that's a good question
ah was our canadian yes
oh yeah
how many people got this with uh
on their real on their real eon if you
only get this one
what if you have a white panda open
mouth doesn't support you anymore that's
right that's right buy new hardware
people
if you have an eon you're next buy a
common too
[Music]
cool sounds good goodbye youtube
thank you for joining us i know you wish
you were here
but you're not but if you want to be
here you can
send an email to give me a job at
comment.ai
and maybe we'll hire you just grilling
some meats
bye everybody